so you went to ucla what what did you go
for
you know i when i went to ucla i was
under coach bob larson but it was one of
the most diverse school that i think uh
public school that was there and it was
the number one athletic and academic
combination school so
i
don't want to be another athlete who
never got a diploma so the pressure for
me to get my ucla degree was huge on me
and my family and even my mom at one
point is because i was running more
miles now i was getting skinnier so like
you know you should stop this running
thing because you know you're getting
tired you should just get a job like
your brother's that on a desk but i'm
saying mom it's paying for my education
but i also love it you know and then
eventually i started communication with
business and then once i graduated in
1999 i became professional and then
start competing and
you know what a thrill of a lifetime to
graduate from ucla and i said now i can
give ryan a full priority because
definitely did not take prior to when i
was at ucla academics did and and then
you know i did after the training and uh
started doing that and then also
going to sydney australia just to wear
the red white and blue uh singlet it
means so much for me for the country
that gave me opportunities to to be the
best that i can since i was the age of
12. and it was a kind of pinch yourself
you know this is a dream come true so it
was a it was a blessing and uh i
i i wasn't stayed in the village and i
got the flu that was going around i was
i was not in my hundred percent and you
know when you are so fit you are more
prone to get sickness and injury but i
finished 12 they had a prelim for the
10k six point tomorrow with the prelim
for it i was the second last guy to
qualify and i finished the race um 12th
place i was so happy and my dad was
there you know my mom was there my my
brothers were there and they're like my
dad is like this is the dream come true
for america for america i know you're
gonna win tonight son i'm like dad
i have not broken 28 minutes the guys
that i'm competing against they're
running 26 30 i'm like i hope i don't
get laughed you know plus i'm sick but
he was a little bit disappointed so you
got to think positive you know but i
said that
you know highly good wrestling from
ethiopia together from kenya those guys
are a minute and a half faster than i am
but i hope to give my best shot and i
did i finished 12 but before i left the
stadium i said
i'm happy to represent our country
and the olympics but next time around i
hope to make the team and also win a
medal for our country and you know in
2004 uh i had i hadn't made the 10k team
and the marathon but the marathon such a
it won the history over me because my
chances of meddling was better than the
10k because i was a national champion
american record holder in the 10k
whereas in the marathon this is my
fourth marathon i was the 39th fastest
guy in the field the chances were not
pretty but to be in athens greece where
the olympics started where the marathon
got its name from and to you know to be
a hot hilly and humid uh challenging
circumstance i think it's not going to
favor world record so i said you know
what i got to put my grit down and
do the proper training and we worked
hard with dina caster who was the female
runner who got bronze medal and her
coach jovi hill coach joe vigil and my
coach bob larson we kind of secluded
ourselves in mammoth lakes and train
hard and
to be able to go to athens and be able
to you know win two medals for uh for
our country and win a silver medal for
me but i met my dad the first time in
five years in athens greece before going
to italy to be able to be there and win
that medal meant so much to me
wow
wow
where do your parents are your parents
still alive
fortunately yes my parents are still
alive and they're in san diego
california where i grew up uh and uh
yeah they're they're blessed you know we
always celebrate october 21st through
call phone calls or
uh
because that was the rebirth of our
family you know and when we first came
to the united states i will never forget
that day you know um october 21st 1987
we're coming up now and
you know 34 years almost so it's a
blessing and
you know whenever i get the opportunity
to spend time with them it's always a
joyful moment
yeah yeah do you um
i feel like you you're
you have intention you have depth and
you have
integrity um i'm wondering
you know
where do you get that from and is
religion or spirituality a part of your
life
um was that was that ever a part of your
life
oh
absolutely um uh greek orthodox is what
i was raised and uh be able to just i
know been an immigrant and it was not we
were not going to church as much because
we would location to the location to
different locations but
i was baptized when i was four years 40
days old and and be able to just kind of
believe in
god and my my dad always said you know
when he was in that journey of 225 miles
he was gun point at one point but the
gun never went off so he says if god
it wasn't in my life that would be the
end of it but he feels to that this day
you know my journey to make that and
survive
there's a higher power in god to allow
us the life that we have and
you know for us when we're very of the
fortunate ones that have come out of
third world country and make a living
for our life but we know better than
anybody or anybody we just feel very
fortunate that god has given out this
mercy this journey and us to be
faithful and and believers to be able to
be the best that we can but yeah it's
important to uh
understand where you came from for me i
go back to eritrea and after i did my
first marathon in new york in 2002 i
went to eritrea to see to see for the
first time and kind of remember a little
bit when i was
10 years old but you know you kind of
forget sometimes where you came from and
when i went back to see that i was able
to
relive a little bit you know how people
were surviving no electricity no running
water uh they gotta go
you know and complaining about my last
40 minutes of the marathon was kind of
small scale versus people are from
sunrise to sunset they're working
diligently and for me it was just two
hours three hours of hard work which
nobody forced me to do i enjoyed doing
it and it was my profession so to look
back gives you strength to what you
could potentially do because
you are grateful for those opportunities
you know you asked me earlier you know
in 2008 was i had a big
big mishap you know after winning silver
medal in athens after getting second in
new york 70 days later and third in
boston you're like i'm ready to find out
when you know which marathon i'm gonna
win but you don't always get what you
think you deserve and i had a
2008
november of 2007 the trials were in new
york city marathon where i had made a
name for myself and
unfortunately you know my good friend
ryan shea passed away for having cardiac
arrest and i finished eighth in the race
so it was just like and i learned after
the finish that my good friend has
passed away i just kind of went to the
ground and couldn't get back up
people lift me up i couldn't walk i was
on my knees and elbows crawling like a
10 month old baby because i don't fall
but it was just but eventually 10 weeks
later we realized that i have perfect
stretch fracture and because when life
is taken away from you injury is the
smallest part of that element and uh i
kind of put it two together and i say
you know what but somehow somewhere you
have to move forward when things get
challenging and circumstances are hard
on you and i just remember
believing and also praying with my wife
and my brother i said i know what i did
in training did not exemplify the
results i wanted to hear because my wife
is like when she saw me on my knees and
nobody's moving from one place and
another in the hotel she's like this is
not a way to make a living you have a
college degree i got my college degree
we got to do something else i said well
faith god has something if that's god
says this is it i'm okay with it i have
my silver medal to prove it and and not
to prove anything else i'm
completely happy but i knew down deep
there was more that i could do and you
know i said my olympics will be the new
york city marathon i can't wait another
four years and to be able to just run
the new year's marathon wearing that usa
jersey and be able to win it and a
personal record time is you know is
there's hope if there's hope and there's
faith and amazing things can happen
don't give up
in the moment you know just believe in
yourself believe in your team and great
things are waiting for you
do you have a mantra or something that
you say to yourself when things are hard
yeah i usually say i pray
but i also say run to win which means
getting the best out of yourself you
know sometimes you everybody's hurting
when you're running 26.2 miles you're
gonna struggle at one point another but
you know that so you got to say okay the
beauty of running is okay let's scale
back a little bit to you know if you're
going
9 45 or 9 30 pace so okay let's go to
the you know 9 50 and get it back and
then we want to go finish at 9 30. you
know you have to have those internal
dialogue within yourself on your team so
for me sometimes i pray hey you know
when i was running the 20 then 2012
olympic games i was ready to drop the
towel i was really struggling
i was 30 37 years old and i thought it
was my last olympics i was
at 21st place at the halfway mark and my
goal was to win top three or personal
best and i know what's gonna happen so
i'm like you know what
this church looks a good place to drop
out but then i realized looking down i
said i have that usa jersey how many
people would love to be in my shoes and
i came positive thinking i prayed i said
god let me let me get a second group you
know again second group and then just
running with them he said maybe i could
be one of those guys and then eventually
from 21st place i'm in 15th i'm in 10th
and with 5k to go i was in sixth place
my coach pointed out six fingers i'm
like
wow this is you know and you're barely
trying to finish this as you're
presenting your counter keep going and
you know amazingly you don't know what
happens sometimes people get drug tested
and they test positive not in the moment
but down the road and i said i gotta get
out fourth place and i remember the
santos my friend from new york from
brazil who run new york he was with me
now with with a 500 meter to go i have
to pass him but i said good job the
santos bound in my mind i'm thinking go
past him as fast as he can
and i kind of see the our flag on the
left side should i grab the flag or
shine that because he's trying to chase
me down and i grabbed the flag and came
in fourth place so be in the moment and
and say run to win getting the best out
of yourself sometimes even though you
feel
given up
if you're not injured or medically
wounded just stay with it because bother
things it will teach you more about
yourself and how to overcome adversity
in those situations what you can do when
things go perfectly even though
sometimes you struggle to the finish
line
that's good advice
do you
have or feel
like you have a certain purpose like an
overlying
life purpose a message
something that you want to show people
do accomplish have make peace with
do you feel a sense of purpose for
something specific
i'm a believer and obviously god has a
purpose for me on this earth and that
our purpose is to influence people to
run it and i
uh i wish i could say that when i was in
seventh grade i wish i could say that
when i won four ncaa titles or break an
american record but the greatest purpose
for me on the earth was
on
april 21st 2014 uh when i ran the boston
marathon you know as you know i won the
boston marathon but a year prior to that
something was taken away from all of us
mentally physically and some
human being that we could never get back
but
i was there i missed that bombing by
five minutes because i was watching my
fellow runners for four hours class
because i never get this opportunity to
do that i love seeing people run i enjoy
it immensely and i left because i had an
appointment and the bombing happened and
as soon as i got to the fairmont couple
which is not too far away and
i remember
um
bonnie ford from espn.com she asked me
are you scared to bring your family
that same evening or are you going to
come back or what is where are you right
now and i remember telling her
i hope to be healthy enough to win it
for the people i remember saying that
that afternoon and for 365 days you have
that conscience you have to live with
when you see the boston strong or when
you see the red sox doing something or
you know you know t-shirt or hat and
things like that when you travel around
the country you see that it's like
you're praying say god help me that day
hopefully to win and i remember when the
red sox put the finish line
the trophy the world series at the
finish line i was getting worked on
therapy i remember to my
massage therapist saying i hope to do
that
when for the boston on pictures today
and so my purpose to answer your
question did it come true and this is uh
to be influential in terms of sports and
to be there for our runners and to be
able
consciously something my spirit told me
to write the victim's name
on the bib that i wore the night before
and and to be able to just go it went
viral because i i wrote crystal sean
martin and ling i might i know those
other four victims that we lost through
the vomit and the limbs and others
mentally physically that we have lost is
irreplaceable but i feel fortunate
enough to be able to tell my story and
be able to carry their names and give a
little bit of hope and that's my purpose
to give a lot of hope for people to get
the best out of themselves
you've done that through your whole life
i mean look at where you look at where
you came from and look at what you've
accomplished do you um
coming back around to uh to the boston
marathon in particular all right like do
you have some final advice for me for
all the runners really i mean this is
for anybody who runs marathons this is
applicable but um you know something to
think about a mindset certain things
that you've mishapped along the way that
learn for yourself when you were younger
i mean hit me what do i need to know
what's some good advice
um
marathon is a metaphor for life patience
is a virtue and boston is a test for
marathoning i know you haven't done any
other marathons or for those of you that
are doing marathons for the first time
boston is a challenging course but we
get excited we guess a narrow road at
the beginning and i made that mistake my
first marathon i went out fast and kind
of said what did i do that for
so what you want to do is in the
marathon if you can make it your last
mile the fastest you're going to have a
great time you're going to enjoy it and
the friendship especially after what
we've been through for the with the
pandemic and other things you know this
is a celebration 26.2 miles is a
celebration the hard work is done now uh
paper is is the net
where you kind of right not as much just
kind of be healthy be mentally
physically and spiritually in the same
page and say hey i'm gonna go out there
and have fun and have a good time with
the people that are running there
because that's the beauty of of running
you know you just enjoy each other and
and palestinians know their sports you
know with all the support they have
about on patreon stay there they
understand the big celebration from
hopkinton to boston is on so they're
gonna have a great appreciation and uh i
think it's wonderful that you know we
get to run again and uh because you know
they've been uh you know consolation in
the past so this is
we've been injured or wounded now we
come alive too and we don't take
anything for granted just be able to
appreciate it and
you know we we all have worked hard but
now the celebration becomes and i want
to wish you the best on all the runners
because
marathon should do once in your lifetime
after that it becomes optional so i'm so
happy for you that that's out of your
bucket list but hopefully we will hook
you up into this marathon thing or have
marathons and it's a great community